what is going on there reject nation greg here
today i am finally about to watch a movie that
every one of my friends circle everyone even
strangers who come up to me or like hey man
big fan of the real rejects everyone makes me feel
left out for not having seen this movie everything
everywhere all at once this is getting unanimous
praise all around and i grew up on michelle yo
film so i'm already very much inclined to see this
film yet i've never even seen a trailer for it so
i know nothing about it and it has something to
do with multiverses i know it starts michelle yo i
know it features my boys from marshall club brian
and andy i'm very much excited to see what they
do in this film because if you haven't seen their
channel marshall club please go check it out it is
awesome stuff even did an interview with andy
here on the channel that was like an hour long but
yeah i mean the conversation here's how the real
conversation goes almost with everyone i talk to
someone is telling me why they don't like doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness and then
it's instantly followed by but but have you
seen everything everywhere all at once if doctor
strange did that oh man then that would be a
good movie then that's literally the conversation
all the time but yeah guys this is just
reaction highlights full length watch
alongs where you sync up with the time code
available for our super sexy rejects over at
our patreon page we cover a whole bunch of
movies and shows over there reaction highlights
and watch-alongs included at the same tier if
you guys can please go ahead and leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated helps designing
the algorithm and a comment while you're at it
and subscribe and click that notification bell
because we got a lot in the pipeline right now
i mean we got koi's comic corner going you know
we got our regular shows and movies that we're
covering whatever trailers come out at the
same time i'm gearing up to start releasing
these videos with it for og real rejects fans
salamander sally who's doing a marvel react
series i mean she hasn't seen most of the marvel
movies so a few of them are re-watched most of
them are a first time watching hoping to start
delivering those in july thank you all for being
here and thanks to the prepper boys for helping
us edit down these highlights you've been a
major part of the channel especially in the
last year let's see what all the hype is about
that's a cool shot
it's a good match good
whoa wicked it starts off on america
she's gonna be going through a multiverse
looking at reflections of herself
but
yeah but asian household you're always going to
look for your parents approval and never get it
a divorce hi evelyn mrs wong hey mom
becky becky says she you know me i always
he make chinese just one word tough so easy
and the way you two are dressed i'm sure i'm
not the only one calling him he i mean her
you and becky can stay here and decorate
whoa i know you haven't always liked becky okay
i like becky she is very nice you are very lucky
haha
this
embrace the gayness joy wait please
i have something to say to you what
you have to try and eat
healthier oh no that's all we do
oh no god damn it
this movie surprisingly feels very
personal for me already goddamn
oh cool many chapters i could tell i'm
going to be crying already it's already
like touching me on like so many personal sciences
you may be in grave danger what the [__]
what hey yo why you don't
know all these apps on my book
what the hell
follow these instructions don't even talk
to me about this because i won't remember
talk to you soon ah okay everyone was right this
movie is amazing on every for every level it's
amazing oh i am so digging this i was just
hoping that you could explain this i thought
that was jamie lee curtis wait is that jay really
cursed how is a laundromat owner a karaoke machine
could constitute a business expense i am a
singer evelyn sing a song for her no no please
what what is watsu it's a water
massage what is about to happen
this music is phenomenal
they don't know you and i are in this universe yet
i'm here because we need your help very busy today
i've spent years searching for the one who
might be able to imagine this great evil
with an even greater good and bring back
balance all those years of searching
have brought me here i know it's a lot to
take in right now mrs wang hello god i'm
loving this this is so good this is so [__]
good i am going to bring that sorry everyone
unless you can help me with my taxes
she reminds me of my mom so much man
it's not my mom would handle this every
disappointment has led you here to this moment
don't let anything distract you from it
this movie just swells you so much emotion
holy [__] oh god this is just a photo
universe we're using for communication
if you want to redo you're going to resubmit i
will be in contact soon i think my other husband's
you will have until you've got the office
tonight to bring everything in 6 p.m oh tomorrow
i have no idea how far i'm into this
movie but i already think this should
win best pitcher and best director and
best lead performance this is amazing
i'm not ready to fight maybe we don't
have a choice gosh sweet shoes to what
i'll get you out of this stop coming here oh buddy
that one right there the chinese lady no
it's all he's wrong okay i need you to
get on the ground with your hands behind
your head damn brad's an actual character
oh the wise oh [__] oh [__] cool
oh man
you know marshall club was very much involved
in this choreography because brighter andy
nice that's a weight to it
yikes
i like watching classic jackie
chan cinema baby just with a lot
more kinetic editing and directing what
fragile branches your self-worth rests
oh my god what the hell i love the filmmaking
choice to keep changing dimensions of the screen
from like four by three to widescreen as you're
hopping through dimensions that's so cool it's
called first jumping i need you to learn how to do
it right now right now it may be your only chance
of getting out of your life wicked you've been
feeling it too and you stay up at night wondering
to yourself how can we get back but that begins
with finding the one who can stand up to jobu's
perverse shot of chaos and you think it's me yeah
this is a better multiverse movie than orchestra
already i feel it yeah calculating roots okay some
paper cuts four of them one between each finger
paper that's only happening it's impossible
there we go one
three all right come on come on come on stay
with me that is not bearable you can feel it
she's got a rug no she can jump somewhere she
can fight she's not ready jump like that would
fry most people she's not most people she's not
most people she's god dave evelyn you developed
an algorithm that calculates which statistically
improper action will place you in the universe
on the edge of your local cluster which then
slingshots you to the desired universe kung fu
universe the next best pass i'll break your
own arm or take a nap you're not sleepy are you
i love you wait no
she's in a local divergent universe no
no she's gone home to finish the taxes
i need to go i need to find the right
evelyn and this one no it's not the one
is [__] amazing i love you take a nap
wow turn down for what
i love you i love you
yes yes yes
oh this is [__] great
oh god damn
i already want to re-watch this movie
it was beautiful
what if i want to go back to
the other universe shut it down
shut it down you hear me
come back okay okay okay i'm
a mind experiences every world every possibility
commanding the infinite knowledge
and power of the multiverse
ah she still meets him
goddamn great ass movies y'all recommending
me making me cry my eyes out all goddamn
jump to another combat universe
i feel yourself it's always
this movie is so overwhelming
joy why do you look so stupid
wow
oh my god
jesus what did you jump she's
off the damn map holy god
it's crazy you're starting to
get it where are you gonna go
oh that is disturbing oh that's so gross
whoever the daughter is she's amazing i'm
i don't know who that actress is she's
incredible i've seen thousands of evelyn's
but never i ever like you you have so
many goals you never finished dreams
you never followed you're living you're
worth you what i cannot be the worst
what about the hot dog one no most people
only have a few significant out in the life
path so close to them you're capable of anything
because you're so bad at everything interesting
weakness is her strength joy why are you here
i have no [__] clue hey gentle language
what the [__] are you doing
wow she is distracted wow it's only protocol
it gives her one less universe to access
oh god no there's no way but it's a sacrifice
that is necessary to win the war okay
you must do it no no no no way in
hell no it's only a matter of time
before you become just like her
what the [__] i cannot lose another loved
one to the darkness don't worry you won't
oh oh oh god i love how introspective the
multiverse journey is making the evelyn
character your time is up find your jumping pads
this is the most beautiful looking
film i've seen in a while man
cool
oh yes is he dead
see not dead go
go show
what the [__] is she about to fight a
dog does my baby want to go for a walk
you gotta be [__] me
cut out this drunken master inspiration
[__] chad
yes yes
god suspended say dream come true for this guy
what happened i think they lost their
stomach power i'm you know the jumping pad
oh god
oh
oh damn andy and brian the same scene fantastic
oh it's hanging out of him
[__] yeah oh [__] yes
wow what a shot
i'm sorry evelyn
crank like quality do this
awesome
incredible stop working this
come on i love this guy who is
the husband and and daughter man
i'm grateful that chance was kind enough to
let us have these last few moments together
oh man ah you still can't see what's happening
no i see more clearly than ever before
wow
um
oh she's multiverse happened
it's quite significantly
hot dog hands that is really disturbing can you
go help my dad with the party go go thanks babe
guys so
so immersive
you can see
how everything is just a random
rearrangement of particles
i have no idea what you
are talking about but i can
crazy but you see how everything
gets washed away in a sea
of every other possibility
yup i'm glad i did not watch this before doctor
stretch i would have definitely
compared the [__] out of it
oh god hit me
the mirror
i know the joy and the pain of having you as my
mother i would only do the right thing for her
right is a tiny box invented
by people who are afraid
i wasn't looking for you so i could
kill you i was just looking for someone
who could see what i see feel what i
feel mrs wang i need to not even show up
we're just going around in circles laundry attacks
no more running excuse me we're
the owners gotta let it all go
you have left me no option but to authorize the
seizure of your personal and your business assets
no she has entered [__] mode
there's only a few specs of time where
anything actually makes any sense
tear it all down man
oh my god
i gotta see any rockstars easter egg breakdown
video that whoa this movie's so hypnotic
would have thought this scene could be so tender
i wanted to see if i went in could
i finally escape like actually die
my silly husband was probably making things worse
ignore it okay you can let it go what
that was actually fine how i don't know
i just talked to her i know you're all
fighting because you're scared and confused
you can still turn around and avoid all this
huh
please [__] destroy me
so much
oh [__]
feeling a good thing they got your hopes
up so i'm here to save you some time
god i feel like i needed this movie
ah
what did my silly husband say to
you he told me about your situation
god what the [__] is this movie to
how'd they make this mess incredible
you're not i'm you're not unlovable what are you
talking about there is always something to love
even in a stupid stupid universe
oh third eye
evelyn
fight with love pitchmen or the nervous system
with a little bit of help we should be
seeing things that are nice and straight
thank you
good thing you're not alive
but she turned out to be stubborn
aimless a mess just like a mother
and gay just like her in that hot dog universe
oh [__]
wow
oh
i'm tired
i don't want to hurt anymore and for
some reason when i'm with you it just
it just hurts the both of
us yeah just let me go okay
just let her be her own person trust her no
matter what i still want to be here with you
i will always
always want to be here with you so what
i'm just gonna ignore everything
else guys i've all cried out goddamn
no boy it's so moving you might not go
somewhere where you're where your
daughter is more than just this
here all we get are a few specks of time
where any of this actually makes any sense
then i will cherish these few specks of time yes
yes
push the button
what did he say
ah
we can do whatever we want
nothing matters i need bread
nothing does anyone have any orange slices i
do think things are better this is this is a
an improvement and that has
to do with this guest disease
evelyn did you hear me sorry what
did you say well somebody scrolls out
the [__] russo brothers produced this
no i have not seen swiss
army man god damn that was
uh
i need to
stand i need to stand i'll be right back with you
guys just stand around this room for a sec oh boy
i keep an ice pack on my lower back when i film oh
boy holy [__] that was a [__]
experience right there i've never
oh
christ regup recoup i love how i
put this mic up here and i barely
[__] talked all i did was just
get lost in this film so transport
for sure at the beginning i was like it looks
like jamie lee curtis and it is jp leakers
and i never clarify that i realized for
sure it was jamie lee curtis so i bet
there's a lot of comments of people saying
craig it is jamie lee curtis uh how to just
that's what the credits roll that is um
uh so overwhelming i was not expecting that i
didn't know what to expect i thought i was going
to get like a cool it was that it was like a cool
experimental multiverse movie you know and hearing
the uh just run into the mic and hearing that the
you know like brian and annie were in this movie
like okay there's a spot to be like a fight
scene i don't i had no idea i i don't think
anything could have prepared me for this uh that
the amount of hype i have heard about this film
the amount of insane hype did not do it
justice for me this was so wow that was um
it's like i need to rewatch this i need to
go again i need to watch this in the theaters
i'm glad i got to experience
this the first time with
all of you i was not expecting if i fight
choreography bye bye them oh sweet they did the
fight choreography [__] yeah i didn't know that
glad i'm sticking around for the credits uh yeah i
need to process this for a little bit
i guess the one thing i would say while the
credits are rolling is this is the kind of movies
you know like i'm not going to try to sit here and
try to sound all like intellectualize everything
because there's there's so much here on every
front from the from the writing directing the
set pieces the performances the themes and there's
there's so much and it moves at such a incredible
pace this really could have been a movie that
could have been frustrating and annoying and yet
for me it wasn't it's just one of those movies
you feel that's that's what it is you just you
just feel this experience don't overthink it you
know you just go with it you either go with it or
you don't i've never experienced a movie like
this ever this is originality at its finest
and i do not blame anyone who saw this
first and then watch multiverse madness
and then as i've heard that so many times
do not believe i'm sure many of you have to
people that i have talked to who who usually tell
me their opinion about this movie and i don't dive
into it because like now i just want to watch like
i don't get details other than the fact that i
hear people love it but yeah when they compare
this yeah i imagine i would like multiverse of
madness less if i watch this within the same week
of going now there's so much more they could have
done though because this just gets you in every
way it feel like i just fluctuated between it
being exciting and it being like emotional you
know this was a great character study and they
utilized the multiverse traveling for this
character evelyn to truly grow and discover
things about herself learn things about herself
and to have a story that's so massive and so
expansive and so wild and experimental and
trippy but to really just have it be about
like the at its core it's such a simple
story at its core you know it's a story about
uh a mother and a daughter essentially it's
about evelyn and this the pain she's held on
to and how it's affected her appreciation and
her her treatment towards her loved ones and
then living in the shadow of her dad like at its
heart there's just a damn good asian family drama
and then if really but then the
backdrop is this crazy multiverse world
of you know because it's like resentment begetting
resentment generational trauma familial trauma
i mean if you go to my 23andme tests and all
kinds of asian and then italian european stuff
but growing up my identity association
was always italian there's no post credits
my identification was always uh italian
filipino but i i a hundred percent like
primarily grew up with my filipino aside seeing
a lot of the family stuff and especially my mom
my mama always talking to me about taxes all
the time for years about taxes especially when i
started living off a youtube channel always about
taxes yeah there's like definite things that i've
not just in my own you know you know immediate
family but being surrounded by a lot of uh asian
american friends who and being what being privy
to their families and then seeing as some of uh
you know a lot of that is very much reflected
here but they just told such a beautiful story
at the end of it all it's hard it's just such a
it's such a beautiful story conquering through the
power of love that's why i think it's so great
because as as wild as it is and as as heady as
it is it's really so simple and it's amazing
they managed to make a movie that's so easy
to it's so easy for audiences to to to grasp on to
it's a lot to keep up with but i'm never but and
it's overwhelming in in the ways that feel right
you know because you're just getting you kind of
got to get swept up in the tone and the music and
its style and the surprising relationship with
with the irs auditing lady jb lee curtis and how
that forms and learning to put your walls down and
and just be learning to be vulnerable like this
brought out something so vulnerable out of me
uh a like a movie about learning to be more in
tune with how you feel underneath and just just
to be honest with yourself and be honest
with the ones you love but and but also to
appreciate it like such such great simple values
you know told in this like poetic way and and i
i loved how this evelyn character i guess i was
gonna to go out to the kitchen and grab a piece
of bread but i guess i'm talking right now i i
love how this evelyn character as she explores the
universe is every version of evelyn let me adjust
this a little bit yeah yeah right up in my [__]
mouth it's really really so much of what she was
experimenting with so much of what she was seeing
with like the other versions of herself were these
people who were you know kind of dead set and and
sort of like had a calling you know not every one
of them but but most of them seem to have like a
specific kind of purpose and a calling and then
with evelyn being the one who just kind of rejects
the plans and and rejects her true desires
conforms and doesn't actually like in every
universe you start to see reflections of who she
is like i thought that was really cool like even
in her blossoming singing career her dad is still
hovering over her shoulder and watching her our
evelyn that we're watching you know because she's
the one who ultimately kind of failed at so many
things and not going after what she really wanted
to be and she's able to sort of absorb and become
everything and you know because she kind
of feels like she's nothing she can become
everything she's like the wild card i thought
that was so beautiful because so much of this
inspirational message is about learning to let go
and yeah like in in talking on on a universe on a
in a universe level my fiance is obsessed with
uh like astronomy and all that space trust you
even tried getting me to listen to this audio the
other day but my mind was caught up in all its own
and all the things that i had to get done that day
and she wanted me to listen to this you know what
the speech was but they're really popular like one
of the most famous speeches about space the bits i
was able to eventually get lost into is like yeah
you really do realize that if we get caught up in
so much [__] on earth but really you know
our time is so finite it's so limited here
yet we get so caught up in circumstances and the
immediacy and everything about you know society
and satisfying this satisfying that yeah you're
just a tiny tiny tiny tiny tiny tiny fraction
of the universe not even a fraction like the the
universe is so massive and expansive that we might
as well just kind of try to enjoy our lives and
as easy as said as easy as it is to say that um
i do not live by that i just i don't i don't live
by that i get caught up when this is done rolling
i'm gonna be caught up probably most likely and
you know and having to like import this footage
and get everything something to sing and get to
work on editing like it just could immediately be
caught up in that instead of just like let me slow
down a little bit and try to appreciate it and
to tell someone i love them but maybe i'll take
that lesson with me because this was one of the
most inspiring things i've ever seen you know as
someone who loves to write myself is one of those
films that it feels like kind of daunting in in a
sense of god will i ever i could i don't know if i
could ever write something this this great this
grandiose because this was beautifully written
everything was just so [__] thought out like
everything is so thought out and they do not have
the marvel budget like i get it i don't want to
make this video just comparing this to multiverse
of madness but i get it i get why people do it
because yeah there's a lot of very similar plot
driven thing even the [__] villain of the movie
is a scorned scorned woman the nuances they bring
and the performances are so powerful so effective
everyone michelle yo yo she killed it she was
amazing she was everything everywhere all i was
she was amazing holy [__] balls man it wasn't
catching the the the names of the actors uh uh
but you know the ones play joy and and wayman uh
wow holy crap like the you know especially
the guy plays waymon the the the the different
portrayals he had to do like going in and out of
the quirkiness the strong determined fighter of
a husband who's inspired by his universe's evelyn
alpha version right the layman who looks like he
is from a certain perspective looks weak but when
you realize he's not really weak that love and
kindness is his strength and learning to accept
that and be supportive you know i thought it was
such like everyone did such a beautiful job and
that the character joy i forget the the villain
name but her performance too they ask a lot of
everyone here because everyone here does not have
to just do emotionality stuff but everyone has to
be so physical and i just mean in terms of like
the fight scenes but even like the littlest quirks
they have to be so physical about when switching
in and out of these characters you know whatever
they're being affected by multiverse wives
everyone's required to do so much in this film
and they all deliver the dad another great one
like everyone brought so much depth and humanity
and so much more but like this this is across the
board for everyone here they and they all brought
something deeper underneath the eyes if that make
i feel like that makes sense yeah they all brought
something deeper underneath the eyes and i'm like
how do you direct a film like my mind is spinning
right now because i'm like how do you direct a
a film like this how do you get the actors on
board how are the actors absorbing this while
they're making this movie the set photography
the the production design was it was uh was was
wild and like there's things in here where i'm
like god i gotta see a youtube video that that
goes frame by frame on all this all those crazy
like match cuts between all the universe i got i
got to see how that all works um it's like the
kind of movie you want to like study and and
and revisit because yeah this was transportive
you know it's really it's you know as part of
the the weird part about doing the reaction stuff
you have to make commentary especially because
this is that's how you make it more fair use and
of course it has to be cut up but at the same time
you know like the the main goal when you're when
we're covering like a show or movie is just to
do our best to get lost in it but i'm always like
kind of aware there's a camera there and this was
the probably the first movie i've seen ever
with on the maybe i don't know actually it
certainly feels that way though i've never been
that like lost in a in a film before with a
[__] camera pointed at me that really put me
in a a whole new level you know like i forget
about the lights and and all that comment because
yeah i was just lost in it when i bring people
on here i'm like yeah the main thing is you know
uh just experience it and just you know whatever
you're feeling internally let it out you know
whether that be through commentary in between
characters or talking or when uh or just to show
it with your actual emotions that was happening so
subconsciously without me like aware of it at all
like this was breaking me and in internally sure
there's some [__] in with me with identifying
like because my with with like any time i see
old asian people i think of my family
bottom line that's just where my mind goes
i think of my family there's parts of michellio's
character that definitely reminded me of my mom
it's not a one-on-one comparison but there were
enough shades of it that would remind me of my
mom beyond that i don't even think if that was
the case i i still would have been just as moved
you know i was i was insanely moved by this one i
i wasn't expecting to walk into a movie that i was
i was going to be that emotional about because
it's also a love story at the end of the day it's
like it's this love story it's a it's it's a it's
a it's just a story about relation like how did
they do that how they how they make something
that was just so goddamn personal and about
relationships that was so intimate but bigger
than marvel's multiverse madness like how do they
do that and it's also like a film making movie you
know working with the the four by three dimensions
when it's just like this frame black borders on
the side and then going from widescreen to kind
of be like we're in action movie mode and then
knowing when to go full screen like it looks like
they experimented with different lenses throughout
this yeah the amount of insane creativity on board
without making you lose sight of the heart at the
end of the day end of the day heart that was wild
i've never experienced something like this before
i don't see any movie getting better than this
this year i want to watch it in the theaters that
might be one of the greatest things i've ever seen
wow wow it's ethereal the sweeping
it was adventurous ambitious creative
innovative uh i think michelle yo should
definitely be considered for i think all of them
should be considered for oscar consideration
even though i do think oscars are [__]
i think it's just gonna be a big reality show
i do think in terms of performances i know it's
so early on in the year but god damn please
do not forget about michellio's work here
because she was phenomenal like wow
like there's so many different genres
spliced into here god might just flash like how
the [__] like the way they managed to make like
craziness and then go to like the talking like the
rocks and make the rocks feel like such a tender
sweet moment damn this was a movie that creates
passion it's like the simple story just like i
don't want to live in my parents shadows anymore
that's what it all really comes down to and if i
don't do that live under that rule and and forgive
and accept thyself you can have a more loving
grateful life like this is really what it's
all about this is kind of moving i want to like
call people up and talk to them about whoever
seen it because no no one i'm glad everyone
did not it's kind of a big thing something
about me is a lot of times if i go to screen
screenings or premieres i don't really talk to
people too much afterwards because a lot of times
it feels like it's a competition for who can give
out their their review to me like right away you
know that's what everyone wants to do it's like
they they'll ask what'd you think of the movie
but 99 of the people who are asking that are just
waiting to give their review of the film so i just
kind of give like one or two sentences and with
this i'm glad that everyone i know did not review
the movie for me they just kind of gave me like
a quick opinion but just heavily encouraged me
to see it i gotta watch it again i gotta watch it
again and pick up all the details because this was
magnificent and beautiful i thought it might have
been overhyped i thought it was actually at the
end of it i thought it was underhyped and that was
that was a revelation of an experience holy [__]
why would i watch anything else
after this movie thank you guys uh
well i'll talk with you all soon thank you for
being here subscribe click that bell and thank
you to the prepper boys helping me edit down these
highlights especially check us out on patreon